Joe Biden would love if you just forgot
about the time when he flexed his muscle
as Obama's vice president and got a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired the same one
who was looking into the Ukrainian
Energy company barisma his son Hunter
was on the board of
I said we're leaving in six hours if the
prosecutor is not fired you're not
getting the money well son
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid
at the time
but that SOB that Biden got fired isn't
going to be silent former Ukrainian
prosecutor Victor shulkin spilling the
beans to Brian Kilmeade in an exclusive
interview shoken believes Joe Biden and
his son Hunter took bribes
I do not want to deal in unproven facts
but my personal conviction is that yes
this was the case they were being bribed
the fact that Joe Biden gave away one
billion dollars in U.S money in exchange
for my dismissal my firing isn't that
alone a case of corruption
the White House claiming shogun's lying
but you can be the judge of that
kilmeads must see interviewers airing
tomorrow night at eight o'clock Eastern
on one nation and as the liberal media
is starting to see the light on Biden
family corruption the Atlantic putting
out this article which admits that it
now seems quite likely
that Hunter Biden broke some laws are
you going to be watching at eight
o'clock Eastern One Nation Jessica
absolutely I think that everyone should
I think it's really important to hear
from
all sides on these kinds of things as
well to committees who are not answering
any questions sorry I didn't even
interrupt
I I don't get what that's a reference to
but
um Victor shocken though is not the most
reliable narrator for such an event and
he's not under oath he's just doing an
interview and he should go and testify
before committee is under oath if he has
a real story to tell there but all of
the evidence refutes what we saw in that
little preview of the interview
Biden fired Victor shoken with the
support of the entire European Union the
international monetary fund the
Ukrainian Parliament all voted to kick
him out because the guy wasn't doing his
job he wasn't investigating corruption
in defiring him though
the Biden I mean the Obama
Administration the Obama Administration
said yeah they weren't so corrupt that's
not true it is okay
Victor shulkin's Deputy guy named Vitaly
Casco has even confirmed that he wasn't
investigating barisma Maria Ivanovich
our own U.S ambassador to Ukraine George
Kent all confirmed it if you think that
the entirety of the International
Community cares enough about Hunter
Biden's fifty thousand dollars a month
to keep someone in an office why would
Joe Biden want him gone then because he
wasn't doing his job
prosecutors why does he care about this
one guy and who's his son's company why
would he want him gone Jessica why would
we want him gone because he was hired to
investigate corruption and he was not
doing so he won
actually and that's I think you forget
what a great segue so when Devin Archer
testified before the oversight committee
that's exactly what he said he was being
asked about this Victor shokun's role he
told them that he was quote good for
barisma and then he agreed with the
statement that shokin didn't pursue
corruption investigations against
barisma's owner you should watch it it's
the exchange that's not true
who was the state Department's top Point
person on Ukraine okay said that shoken
was doing a good job fighting crime John
Kerry uh was saying the same thing that
chokin specifically was doing a good job
fighting corruption oh and this is in
June of 2015. all of a sudden in January
of 2016 shulkin is corrupt and Joe Biden
says he's got to go now the fact is that
the Obama State Department was in favor
of shokun because everybody knew there
was corruption going on in Ukraine
that's why shokun was hired boroshenko
put him in there to make sure that he
prosecuted corruption and when he got
too close to Prisma that they wanted to
bring to the United States to do
business that's when they said Joe you
got to come in here and save this
country this company or your son
what did you say you said I wasn't
finished and I said well you cut me off
and now go ahead and finish and then
I'll reply
all right in 2016 all of a sudden the
the prosecutor who's so wonderful to the
state department everyone's so grateful
he's there all of a sudden now the
hunter Biden just gets on the board
everybody's like he's got to go
and if you're dangling a billion dollars
don't you think that billion might be
able to force the prosecutor to
investigate barisma why do you need a
whole new prosecutor why couldn't you
just tell him to investigate this
company and Jessica your pushback when
it comes to shoking and bereza in
particular seems to be a firewall set up
to make sure this doesn't come back to
Joe Biden clearly as Jesse pointed out
in the introduction there seems to be a
growing realization across the media
landscape that Hunter was up to ugly
business not just in Ukraine in China
and everywhere else that Air Force 2
served as Jesse has reported on
throughout this week as essentially a
taxi service for Hunter Biden's
businesses and it takes a imaginary leap
a huge creative leap to think that Joe
Biden was at least ignorant if not
involved in all of the ongoings with
this taxi service sure I'll take you to
Serbia sure I'll take you to Spain sure
I'll take you to China sure I'll take
you to Canada what are you doing when
you get there son I don't know Dad
that's amazing I I have never said that
I don't think think that Hunter could be
guilty of wrongdoing what I have said
consistently and people have been
pushing various members of these
committees on this and Sandra you've
done it on your own show where so where
the payments Jason Smith the chairman of
the house Ways and Means was on our
program today where are the payments and
20 million dollars they already found so
why not why not why wouldn't the
president if there's no wrongdoing why
not encourage Congress to turn over any
information that they had Jason Smith
made the point on our show today and I
read verbe we have been stonewalled he
said this is a pattern we are seeing
over and over they are stalling any
Revelations that they can possibly
provide to the committee in regards to
how the justice department blocked the
prosecution of the president's son when
you've lost the Atlantic to your point
the headline in the Atlantic it now
seems quite likely that Hunter Biden
broke laws they're saying as tenderly as
a father may love his struggling son the
president can do better than parent than
nothing wrong Chorus at what point are
they going to say you know what we've
got to start talking we've got to
encourage providing answers to these
questions I
Hunter Biden breaking laws and Joe Biden
breaking laws are very different no one
cares about Hunter Biden they don't he's
an accessory Jessica
he's taking them all over the world and
all of his entire family is getting
there
to his mug shot then hope that it's
Stern okay we'll find out he's a very
handsome man he is a handsome hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else